hey guys matt here with code tech
tutorials today we're going to look at
bungie's c plus plus guidelines and
razors now this is uh just going to be a
quick overview the article is quite long
you're welcome to go read it i'll show
right there is where you can find it
also if you just google search it you'll
find it it just came out
very recently a couple days ago a few
days ago i'm going to start out here
just by reading the top blurb and then
we're just going to basically do a
synopsis
uh overview and this is just for people
who don't feel like
reading it all basically or if they just
kind of want my
take of the whole thing and it is how
you would expect of course bungie makes
destiny 2 they've made a ton of other
games uh pretty famous
and big game developer
all right here we go there's a lot of
teamwork and ingenuity that goes into
making a game like destiny we have
talented people across all disciplines
working together to make the best game
we can however achieving a level of
coordination needed to make destiny
isn't easy it's like giving a bunch of
people paint brushes but only one canvas
to share between them and expecting a
high quality portrait at the end
in order to make something that isn't
pure chaos some ground rules need to be
agreed upon
all right so pretty decent little intro
all right so they have coding guidelines
now this is pretty standard almost every
company that has
a big piece of software that a bunch of
people work on there's always coding
guidelines so they talk a little bit
about this here here are some of the
things they say
all right so don't use the static
keyword directly now i thought this was
pretty interesting
so basically they have a header and they
have a static global and a static local
and it allows us to honest audit
dangerous static functions
efficiently now if you're not sure what
that means i would encourage you to
maybe learn a little more about the
static or i might actually do
a video in my c plus series about that
all right and they mentioned some other
things now some of these things are sort
of odd to me that they're so specific
like braces on their own lines braces
are always placed on a line by
themselves this is not a big deal in my
opinion at all and not something that
should be critically analyzed
as a big deal
all right now there they have an
exception for single line inline
function definitions okay fine
there's got to be something more
important that they can mention other
than braces on their own lines i was
thinking but okay so they
they have a tool auto check and autofix
uh easily identify
guideline violations i think this is
pretty standard too
so let's let's go down a little bit and
read a little more challenges you say
the first challenge is pr is the
programming language that we're using
for game development c plus plus is a
powerful high performance language that
straddles a line between modern concepts
and old school principles all right
well it's one of the most common choices
for aaa game dev
to pack the most computations in the
smallest amount of time all right very
good so let's uh let's move forward a
little bit they say some other code is
20 years old
and some of it needs to be deleted or
updated
all right so
they have about 150 engineers at this
point and about 75 of them are
working on the c plus plus
okay so a lot of this is just
and just kind of write up not not a
whole lot of technical stuff in here
they kind of allude to some technical
stuff but but this is more of like a
more of a general public post that kind
of tries to give a little insight into
what it's like there even if you don't
understand
the language they're talking about so
that's
that's one thing i kind of gathered
okay so they have this concept of razors
which they
simply they basically mean
shaving off complexity or to
cut off stuff you don't need may keep
everything really straightforward favor
understandability
at the expense of time to write so every
line of code will be read many times by
the people many varying backgrounds
prefer explicit but verbose to concise
but implicit okay that's that's a lot to
make explicit but verbose i guess that'd
be like long function names that maybe
are very clear and long
maybe longer variable names that are
very clear about what they are just by
the variable name i always find it
frustrating to go into a new code base
and everything's an acronym and you're
like how am i supposed to figure out
what this is
that is always a bit frustrating
um
sure you can usually eventually figure
it out especially if there's good
comments and a good write-up about it
and it looks like they do snake case
as their naming
convention
another thing
so you can find like arguments online
and forums and threads about
uh naming convention cases and tabs
versus spaces and these are all
essentially the most pointless and
useless bits of
time eatery when it comes to programming
you could be learning about uh something
a new concept instead or or something
there it just doesn't matter is the
point really has no
bearing on anything what your naming
convention is or your
tab space
convention or if you put your opening
brackets on a new line or not that
doesn't mean that it's not important to
have those
because you want everybody writing code
the same way
that way it's
it is basically uniform and easier to
read quickly
if it ever comes up as like an argument
and someone says no we do it this way
and then someone else says no we do it
this way it's a useless argument just
pick one and move on that's all there is
to it so maybe take a vote or something
names and and code syntax it all gets
abstracted away once it's compiled
none of that translates into the final
machine code no matter how you do your
naming convention it does not affect the
performance or anything like that you
probably already know this but just make
it very clear
just tell me which one you prefer for
your code base okay let's move on and
avoid abbreviation yes we already kind
of touched on this
encourage the addition of helpful inline
comments it's fine i think what they
mean by inline is you don't you don't
put them above the thing or below the
thing you just put them to the right
side start a comment and say the thing
to the to the right of it i think that's
what they mean by inline i've never
heard a comment called inline before but
that makes sense all right below is a
snippet of their code you can probably
get a sense of what it's trying to do
let's check out let's check out the code
alright n32
new held milliseconds all right very
descriptive name
oh what they don't use a space before
their equal sign here
that's really weird to me
all right well this is this is nice
because it's very clear that it's the
new held milliseconds often the the
scariness of using the word new
is it it can occasionally look like
you're creating a new pointer or
something
or
assigning a pointer some new data
but obviously it's not the case here so
some people entirely avoid the word new
but they don't seem to care about that
because when you're like doing a code
search for the word new you want to find
where you're
allocating memory right and this would
pop up in there so some people avoid
that in their code basis but then yeah
they seem to be okay with that or they
probably do it differently they probably
don't use new and delete too much
anymore
they probably have it abstracted
differently
all right so they call an update context
their update context which is probably
like since the last frame i'm guessing
get
timestamp millisecond and then minus
this is a member start hold timestamp
millisecond that's like the last time i
think so it's basically the delta time
is what this looks like
all right and then they have some more
stuff i guess we don't really need to go
over all this but they're called let's
uh
let's analyze a few things so they're
calling a function called set output
property value and accumulate
now this is another thing that i
actually
see as a big no sometimes
in cases because
this function does multiple things
and while that can be fine a lot of
times a lot of companies will say or a
lot of code based managers or whatever
will say your functions do one thing all
right
so this does multiple things it says it
sets the output property value and
accumulate so it does it does two things
so that's
maybe that's not bad because it's very
descriptive about exactly what it does
because it's probably just accumulating
the time
and it's setting the output property
value okay
and it looks like they're passing it by
reference the milliseconds so this is a
variable here right and
by putting this reference here it turns
it basically into a pointer
so
this function wants a pointer
to that that seems a little odd to me
i'm not entirely sure why they would do
that i'd have to dig in a little more
but uh
and they probably have the
reasons because
well what i'm thinking here is they
could
let's think about this they could take
this in
by a
uh
const reference right and then just pass
it without having to put this reference
thing here and it would still be very
fast but this function looks like it
wants a pointer to an n32
which is going to make a small copy of a
pointer
rather than passing a reference they're
going to be about the same
the thing is with this
you could change it
they could change the milliseconds so
maybe that's what they're doing with the
accumulate is they're intending on
making a change and that's why it's
not const
but i really have to dig into the
function to know all this now there's a
lot more here
i don't know how much i should dig into
and clearly i mean very critical without
knowing um the rest of their code and
the purpose of it so it's it's very
very possible that they are have things
written in a very specific
manner that i'm not going to understand
from a small snippet but i could tear
apart any of this very specifically and
tell you what exactly what does so if
you like this sort of stuff let me know
i'd be happy to review more code and
analyze what it does here on this
channel i think a lot of people
seem to like that as far as i can tell
all right let's move on avoid
distinction
without difference when possible without
loss of generality reduce mental tax
by prescribing redundant and arbitrary
alternatives i feel mentally taxed
reading that this razor
and the following razor go hand in hand
they both deal with our ability to spot
differences you can write a particular
behavior in code multiple ways and
sometimes the difference between them is
unimportant
uh yeah i agree
okay when that happens we'd rather
remove the potential for the difference
from the code base so the readers don't
need
to recognize they cost brain power to
map multiple things to the same concept
okay yeah i see so by eliminating these
unnecessary differences we can
streamline the reader's ability to pick
up code patterns and mentally process at
a glance
the
infamous example of this is tabs versus
spaces for indentation
or bracket starting on a new line or not
all right it doesn't really matter what
you choose at the end of the day
but the choice needs to be made to avoid
mixed formatting yes exactly
yeah the thing that makes it unreadable
is
like
you might all be using the same editor
that kind of abstracts
uh your tabs and spaces so that they all
have the same thing but then when you
say push it to github or something
github
does like eight spaces for tabs so then
everything that you had aligned
perfectly for everybody once they look
at it online it all looks real wonky and
out of place that's actually the main
reason i personally like spaces is
because
you never know if a tab is going to be
four spaces or if it's going to be eight
spaces on whatever you're looking at so
all this careful alignment you do to
make things look neat and clean it gets
thrown out the window as soon as you
start using tabs and that that's sort of
annoying but in the reality of things a
tab is a slash t right
so the slash t is only two characters
and usually when people use spaces they
use four spaces which is four characters
so the code is a bit smaller when you're
just using slash t rather than four
spaces as far as like size of the file
but also instead of tabs
you can use two spaces
which is the same size as the slash t
that's that's what i tend to do i just
use two spaces i never use four spaces
i'm a two space indenter
don't add me
okay let's move on use american english
spelling color instead of color okay
post increment in general usage
instead of uh pre-increment
okay yeah that's fine you'll see for
loops uh for example use either it's the
same in a for loop because it happens on
a line on its own anyway okay uh we have
these uh symbols
star and ampersand
which is a pointer memory stuff all
right go
next to the variable instead of
the type name
now i've heard an argument
for it being on the left side all right
so for example you can
declare variables
all right so n32
uh
star
uh my pointer and then you can comma and
declare another one like a thing
or my pointer two or whatever but what
this looks like at a quick glance is it
looks like
this one is a pointer
to an n32
and this one's just an n32 but that's
not the case these are both pointers so
when you have it on the left side like
this it's a little more clear that
they're both in 32 pointers
i i tend to stick with it on the left
side instead of the right side but
it's not that big of a deal you just
gotta be careful about that
miscellaneous white space rule in high
level code organization
within a file now most code checkers
will clean up miscellaneous white space
so
like if you have just random white space
at the end of a line
most things will clean that up at least
visual studio does which is nice
alright and number three of the razor
stuff leverage visual consistency use
visually distinct patterns to convey
complexity in signpost hazards the
opposite hand
of the previous razor now we want
differences to indicate important
concepts to really stand out this aids
the code reader okay
so they want there they want something
we'll say drastic to kind of happen when
there's a big thing happening
in the code
is probably what they're saying they
don't want to try to
obscure
important things that are happening in a
line so they basically don't don't want
you to miss something that you wouldn't
want to miss which makes sense example
of something we want really noticeable
in c plus we can use the preprocessor to
remove sections of code from being
compiled based on whether they're
building an internal version only of the
game or not we'll typically have a lot
of debug utilities embedded within the
game that are unnecessary when we ship
so
those will be removed when we compile
for retail okay yeah
we want to make sure that the code
meant to be shipped doesn't actually get
marked as internal only though otherwise
we would get bugs and then manifest in
the retail environment those aren't very
fun to deal with yeah that makes sense
so um
this is pretty standard i think for
uh code bases uh let's see we mitigate
this by making the c plus plus
preprocessor directives really obvious
we use all uppercase names for defined
switches
left align our preprocessor commands and
make them stand out against the flow of
the rest of the code yeah this is all
very standard
so as you can see there if def is
all the way to the left here even though
it's only affecting something in this
function some people might align it with
the rest of the code but all the way to
the left and looks like they do a comma
here to
to specify what it's ending here this is
what i do too uh yeah i think it's
better that way okay some bungee code
guidelines that support this are braces
should always be on their own line
clearly denoting the nest and logic
i guess that is a point if you have a
really long line putting a bracket away
at the end might be off screen so you
might not necessarily know that it's
starting
a new
scope
unless you see it but putting it on a
new line makes it very clear uppercase
for preprocessor symbols
uh platform 164 okay
no space
left
of the assignment operator okay we saw
that earlier
where there's no space here okay and if
they're doing a comparison there is a
space so that's sort of interesting i
actually kind of like that because this
makes it very clear that it's a
comparison
and this is an assignment yeah it makes
a lot of sense in a big code base
because one a very common error very
very common and i've done it a million
times
is uh you make an if statement all right
and you want to check something right
yeah so you go if uh
or 42 42 is a good number and we want to
know if it's 42 or not so normally you
would do this right and then you have
your logic for if it's 42.
but some people accidentally forget this
sometimes uh forget the second equals
and they do this so they think okay i
just want to check if it's 42 this
should be doing it and then their code's
buggy and they're not it's not doing
what they expect and they're like what
the heck is wrong with this this will a
hundred percent of the time evaluate to
true
because value it's setting value to 42
or and it will stay 42. for example this
was 20 and we wanted it to skip over
it's not going to skip over this instead
it's going to assign 42 to value and
that's going to be a true because 42 is
is true the only false value is 0.
this would evaluate to true 100 of the
time
and also assign value 42. so that's
that's just a really common and on and
very easy to make mistake so if you're
not you're not paying a lot of attention
or if your
editor doesn't point things like out
that out to you most of the modern ones
will pick this up and like underline and
be like i don't think you mean to do
this here
you just need to double equals but it
makes a little more obvious when it's
like this that it's assigning leverage
pointer operators
to advertise memory and direction
instead of references to advertise
memory and direction instead of
references okay i actually need an
example for that i don't i don't know
what they mean by
to advertise memory and direction
set of references it's not clicking for
me exactly what they mean by that
because they have all three of the
options
there
all right avoid misleading abstractions
when hiding complexity
signposts characteristics that are
important for the customer
to understand the customer
what do they mean by the customer isn't
your only your internal
coders working on that are you calling
them customers but this just seems weird
to call your employees customers so
avoid misleading abstractions yeah i
think this is just like a kind of a
common sense thing you don't want to
call a function something completely
different than what it actually does you
don't want to call a function
say you want to function to
maybe uh resize an object you don't want
to call that function blow up and right
because someone's going to look at that
and think oh you're they're exploding an
object and no it's just residing it's so
weird example i know but so just make
things clear basically they're they're
kind of saying the same thing here as
they said earlier with the use clear
names type thing okay and but no they go
on to explain a little more here i i
might not be totally right about that
okay so they have class types
start with c enum start with e
m for member variables k for constants
so they start things with these uh okay
yeah it's not a bad convention
i guess i guess it depends what your
editor is like because a lot of editors
you can just basically like hover over
uh your variable and it'll tell you all
about it but in giant code bases the
problem with that is that kind of stuff
gets really slow so often you have to
turn it up turn it off once you have
like thousands and thousands of lines of
code you you might get slowed down by
your by your checking stuff your static
analysis i think is what they call it so
you might want to turn that off once
your code base is huge if you're getting
tired of it freezing and locking up not
working right stuff all right no
operator overloading for non-standard
functionality
probably a good idea
function names should have obvious
implications get blank
should have a trivial cost try to get
blank may fail but will do so
gracefully compute blake and query blank
are expected to have a non-trivial cost
okay favor patterns that make the code
more robust
it's desirable to reduce the odds that
future change or conflicting change
in another branch introduces a
non-obvious bug
yeah this is kind of a big deal with
a lot of people working on a
big code base a merge conflicts can be a
complete nightmare
if uh
especially during crunch time where
everybody's like
doing stuff very quickly and suddenly
uh the main merge point gets locked up
and then nobody can do anything until
that's fixed and
that kind of gets me real bad so
just write perfectly logical code no
bugs will happen easy right well yeah
it's not that easy all right
so here's some some of their coding
guidelines
uh initialize variables at declaration
time i totally agree with this you
should always do this i know some people
will argue that well it initializes to
zero
anyway or whatever
sometimes it switches if you're in like
debug or
release mode or if you use a different
compiler if you're supporting multiple
systems
it might not initialize to what you
think it's going to initialize to so
yeah always always initialize
i think it's a good rule follow const
correctness principles for class
interfaces
i i don't know
i don't know why this would be a
guideline maybe there's something i'm
not thinking of here but
const correctness is like
it is a standard of c plus plus
basically you always want to follow
const correctness i'm not sure why they
need a guideline
for that it's it's more like
just yeah something you do in general a
single return statement at the bottom of
the function
all right that's that's pretty good for
clarity i'm guilty of not doing this
i often have like returns right at the
beginning if something fails or
something like that but
it depends what you're doing a single
return at the bottom is probably a good
good call it's definitely a little
cleaner you don't have to search through
the rest of the function for like oh is
it possibly returning somewhere else is
there a reason why it's not getting to
where you know stuff like that leverage
asserts to validate state okay so they
they just assert it looks like if it's
gonna fail then it's just gonna
fail the assert and
crash anyway all right avoid
native arrays and use our own containers
that's probably a good idea the native
arrays are a little dangerous
especially if slightly misused and you
run off the edge of the memory all right
centralized life cycle management
distribution life cycle across systems
with different policies makes it
difficult to reason about correctness
when composing systems and behaviors
instead
leverage the shared toolbox and idioms
avoid managing your own life cycle
whenever possible
okay
sure let's dig in a little bit instead
of each engineer needing to come up with
their own way of managing memory we have
a bunch of tools already written i can
use as a drop-in solution okay so
they're all
uh just doing the same thing basically
they don't want everybody trying their
own methods and things getting lost in
translation and stuff like that all
right some budgie bungee cody guidelines
that support this razor
are use engine specific allocation
patterns do not allocate memory directly
from the operating system avoid using
stl for game code
no standard template library i guess
they have their own so
that's fine all right recap they have a
little recap here
uh i'm not i'm not going to go over the
recap
but hey looks like they're hiring over
on their career page so if this kind of
stuff interests you
you could go
apply wow what a post thank you bungie
for supplying this to the general public
it's it's very cool that they release
something like this you don't see stuff
like this out too often in the wild so
yeah that's gonna do for this video let
me know what you think leave your
comments down below see you guys next
time and also a few quick announcements
in case you haven't heard
the patrons back up and running or we're
going to be given member shout outs in
every video there's a
[Music]
the amount of times i've been trolled by
my phone in this video there's a new
tier that will get you in contact with
me on a semi-regular basis if you want
like tutoring or me to review your stuff
or something like that there's also a
discord for that sort of thing where we
have other members and everyone's super
cool there and yeah so
join up unite let's do things and
there's probably more announcements that
i'm not thinking of so i guess just stay
tuned peace out guys
[Music]
you